yasmine beau gosse bonjour l'argent
alors nous sommes là ce matin pour
parler d'un événement d'envergure qui
aura lieu à vancouver
qu'est ce que c'est au fond c'est wons 2
les verts c'est gérer la plus grande
conférence sur les droits de la femme et
la justice entre genres qui se tiendra
lieu du 3 au 6 juin à vancouver
alors j'imagine vous êtes une personne
dynamique très très motivés ce qui est
quand même quelque part encourager votre
sélection pour sa conférence gérait j'ai
fait quand même pas mal d'activités qui
m'ont permis d'être choisi
ça a commencé en algérie avec dale green
food banks est une banque alimentaire on
faisait de la collection des denrées
alimentaires pour les familles
nécessiteuses
même si j'étais jeune à l'âge de 18 ans
j'étais quand même gérante des groupes
de volontaires qui collectait les
denrées et puis après ça je me suis
déplacé au caire c'est là où j'ai
commencé vraiment à m'intéresser au
domaine de la politique les droits du
culte la liberté des femmes et
la fin c'est à dire je dirais la plus
grande activité que j'ai fait c'était de
lancer et d'initiative
ça s'appelait un tel feuilleton
interculturel initiative c'est à dire
l'initiative interreligieux et
interculturel à l'université américaine
du caire où on essayait de parler des
sujets tabous de de militer pour la
liberté de culte que ça soit pour les
femmes ou pour les hommes en egypte et
ailleurs dans le monde
c'est pour cela que j'étais choisi je
tairai en effet ben je rappelle en
passant que vous êtes vous avez été
étudiante dont en mathématiques dans
cette université l'université américaine
du caire
et comment fait-on pour partir
d'étudiantes en mathématiques à
militante des droits de la femme des
droits de l'homme des droits de culte en
fait l'université américaine
ces universités de dar libéraux
ça veut dire en tant qu'étudiant ont
fait pas seulement que notre spécialité
mais on prend beaucoup de cours en
philosophie en histoire en politique
et j'aimais ça parce que ça me
permettait de m'intéresser à beaucoup de
domaines et de je dirais développer mes
capacités et mes compétences qui n'était
pas limitée aux mathématiques
donc côté tu te faisais mathématiques et
statistiques
et dans mon temps libre je me l'étais à
pour des causes dans lesquelles je
croyais et c'est pour cela et c'est pas
la seule activité qui avait réclamé à
l'université américaine du caire
on a beaucoup de clubs qui exercice dans
divers domaines ça m'a donné la chance
justement de deux décès y ait beaucoup
d'expérience et de me focaliser vers la
fin dans ce domaine là tout à fait je
rappelle également que vous êtes
actuellement à la maîtrise en
statistiques à l'université mcgill
ouais c'est correct c'est pas trop
compliqué ok si parce que j'imagine les
femmes et les chiffres ça fait pas
toujours bon ménage
oh que je suis je suis
comme andy ram et guy lundi women and
matt adhap donc il ya beaucoup de filles
qui font mathématiques et statistiques
notamment giresse et pas par rapport aux
gens c'est plus par rapport à nos
compétences et nos centres d'intérêts je
leur ai dit d'entrée de jeu vous
débordez d'énergie parce que vous
intervenez pas mal à l'université dans
l'événementiel dans l'organisation des
événements je veux dire dans la
communication même de l'université dites
moi comment ça se passe à mes guides je
suis pas aussi actif parce que
franchement la maîtrise prend beaucoup
de mon temps mais arrive ainsi
américaine oblige était très très active
chaque année j'écrirai dans un magazine
the times en arabe et j'étais aussi chef
de rédaction de 2 du magazine spécial je
participe à beaucoup d'événements
beaucoup de conférences et si la
concernant le leadership le rôle de la
femme
voilà est-ce qu'on va me dire assez
brièvement en quoi consistera votre rôle
votre participation à cette conférence à
vancouver alors j'adore la première
cette partie si tu es dans différents
ateliers qui va avoir lieu sur justement
l'émancipation de la femme
les droits de la femme la santé sur tout
ça c'est dans ce cas là je serai
participants s'attendaient à prendre je
vais écouter le deuxième c'est que je
vais participer à un panel elle qui
parlera du rôle de la religion pour
pouvoir les droits de la femme parce que
j'ai quand même pas d'expérience pas mal
d'expérience dans le domaine
interreligieux et interculturel
j'ai dû à faire avec des hommes j'ai dû
à faire avec des dés des leaders
religieux et j'ai aussi dû à faire avec
beaucoup de
sans surprise comment dire ça sam chit
comme en dix ans sa censure à sion sans
sur la censure pas l'intention dans son
inspiration c'est l'ascension où la
censure et c'est pour cela que j'ai été
invitée pour participer à ce panel où je
vais parler avec d'autres activistes
dans le domaine des gens de religion des
femmes qui sans militante dans son
domaine pour réfléchir sur les
problématiques qui se pose est comment
peut-on inclure les leaders religieux
pour minimiser au plus tôt éliminer la
violence surtout contre les femmes et
ouvrir les portes à la participation
féminine dont la religion en général qui
est on peut dire très tabou dans
beaucoup de sociétés d'un jour d'une
façon plus générale c'est quoi les
objectifs de cette conférence la haut
font alors la conférence a pour but de
cesser de rassembler tous les militants
dans le domaine des droits de la femme
de la justice entre les genres c'est une
opportunité deschamps je dirais pour
promouvoir toutes techniques tout
méthodologie dans partout dans le monde
qui se passe pour promouvoir ce domaine
là et aussi d'élargir son network et
faire des connaissances avec des gens
qui peuvent nous aider plus tard et
aussi de discuter les problématiques et
comment peut-on au niveau individuel et
au niveau collective est les résoudre et
c'est une conférence qui est organisée
par les nations unies non c'est pas ça
c'est women deliver c'est une c est une
organisation indépendante en elle-même
qui est organiste qui est basé au canada
qui est basé au canada qui fait donc
venir des participants de quel pays
partout dans le monde encore tout dans
6000 participants de partout dans le
monde les participantes ya des
journalistes des étudiants des
activistes des militants des avocats des
politologues de partout et de tout
domaine et dites-moi si en même temps un
plan beaucoup plus concret commandant dé
vous capitalisez je veux dire exploiter
les acquis d'une telle conférence à
l'avenir ben pour moi même j'aimerais
bien faire cette année network surtout
dans la région du moyen-orient et
l'afrique du nord
parce que qu'on vous a fait savez
l'algérie est entraîne c'est votre pays
d'origine c'est mondial mais oui bon il
va où louis est en lien entre end avoir
une révolution de sourire dont la femme
prend un rôle principal et donc
j'aimerais bien connecté avec les
voisins les pays voisins pour pouvoir
surtout par exemple la tunisie et
l'egypte le liban des pays où aucun même
les droits de la femme évolue chaque
année de connecter avec eux de savoir
comment peut-on exploiter cette
révolution pour justement mettre en
avant la femme algérienne son rôle et
comment préparer la société à accepter
ce changement par rapport à la femme
alors certes on va on va creuser
davantage son nouveau concept que
j'apprends la révolution du sourire
comment est il né
ces saignées de la rue de la part du
peuple qui voulait changer son avenir
par ses propres mains d'une manière très
pacifique avec du sourire sans violence
et pour ça on appelle justement à la
ville al révolution du sourire c'est à
dire tout se passe pacifiquement son
hockey knockin aucun retour à la
violence
aucune réponse violence à la provocation
l'union
le support de l'autre et surtout le fait
de rester unie jusqu'à atteindre notre
but final dont en fait c'est une
dévolution qui concerne la société dans
sa globalité c'est juste et les fins non
non c'est tous les algériens dit que et
c'est je dirais pas que c'est la
première fois mais cette phase iib la
présence féminine dans la rue elle est
considérable elle est primordial que ce
soit en façade on les sorties du mardi
c'est là où les étudiants sortent on va
que toutes les étudiantes presque sont
présentes et aussi le vendredi comme
tout le monde sort aux biens dans la
diaspora où la présence féminine ne peut
pas négliger
nous n'allons pas conclure sans parler
de ce vin de démocratisation dont on
soif tous les algériens qu'est ce que
vous en pensez le départ de bouteflika
l'exigence de plus de démocratie qu'est
ce que cela vous suggère d'abord
j'applaudis mon peuple et moi même parce
que si vous m'aviez parlé au moins de
janvier c'est à dire avant le 22 février
le 22 février que la première la
première marche que le peuple algérien a
fait j'aurais dit que c'est impossible
que le mon peuple fera un geste pareil
j'adore donc je nous applaudit pour tous
courage pour laisser la peur à côté je
crois mon peuple je crois un an à nos
demandes et je vois une vague d'espoir
une vague de détermination qui ne va pas
lâcher jusqu'à la concrétisation réelle
de nos demandes communes où le tapis en
vie et bien voilà yasmine google je
rappelle donc vous êtes étudiante à la
maîtrise en statistiques à l'université
mcgill et que vous êtes venu nous voir
ce matin pour qu'on parle de cette
conférence qui a lieu à vancouver c'est
du 3 au 6 juin
exact voilà c'est organisée par l'efs
oui même de l'ifa en tout cas je
souhaite le plein succès de cette
conférence et je vous remercie
infiniment devait d'être venu nous voir
merci pour l'invitation ça fait un
énorme plaisir
rien